[Music]
breaking news this Wednesday night about
the RCMP the head of the force
commissioner Brenda lucky reveals she's
retiring what's behind her departure
incredible rescue the family freed in
Turkey after being trapped for more than
a week
as Canadian doctors head to Syria to
help exhausted colleagues there
the truth is out there more detail on
the U.S tracking that Chinese spy
balloon and the capability of having
eyes in the sky
plus actor model and international sex
symbol it's gone remembering the
Fantastic Voyage of Raquel Welch
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with news about the head of the
RCMP Brenda lucky who is appointed to
the role in 2018 says she's leaving
knowing that she did her best lucky was
the first permanent female RCMP
commissioner she says her departure is a
personal decision but she has faced
multiple challenges over the years and
her appointment was not open-ended our
Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson
is with me Mercedes lucky says it was a
difficult decision can you give us some
context around her departure well I'm
not sure how much of her decision it
really was Donna I've been speaking to
senior federal government sources on the
political and the National Security side
for weeks and they had been telling me
that the government was not planning to
extend Brenda Lucky's mandate and that
is what would have had to happen in
March when her five-year term expires
they were not very happy with her
performance over the years and as we can
remember there have been a number of
tragedies and questions about the rcmp's
capabilities while she was in the
commissioner's chair everything from
that tragic mass shooting in Nova Scotia
and how the RCMP responded to it and the
lack of transparency to what I'm told
was essentially the final Breaking Point
with how the commissioner handed handled
the Convoy protest that was here in
Ottawa so the federal government had no
intention of extending her according to
my sources Brenda lucky though still
seeing this as a win in her final
statement she says that as commissioner
I was asked to modernize and address the
rcmp's internal challenges this was a
significant mandate and with the support
of my senior executive team and the
commitment of all RCMP employees we've
accomplished a lot all right Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thank you well there
is still a limited amount of information
being made public about the objects shot
from the sky over Canadian and American
airspace but audio recordings have
emerged of the U.S fighter jet Pilots
before they shot down one of those
objects over Lake Huron it reveals they
weren't sure what they were looking
looking at the origins of that object
and two others remain a mystery but
there are reports American intelligence
had eyes on the first balloon from the
moment it was launched off the south
coast of China Mackenzie gray reports
just moments before they took their shot
over Lake Huron U.S fighter jet Pilots
set over cockpit audio that they were
perplexed by what they saw
[Music]
especially smaller than a car that small
size is making the recovery mission of
the unidentified objects challenging
ships and helicopters from the Canadian
Coast Guard are combing like Huron and
in Yukon the RCMP are searching a 3 000
square kilometer area but in both cases
they might come up empty-handed let's
make sure we recover them if we can
because I think that's also a working
assumption there is a possibility that
we won't be able to recover them given
the remoteness given the challenges
given the deterioration Etc but there
was no challenge in recovering
significant debris from the Chinese spy
balloon off the coast of South Carolina
a balloon that the Americans are
believed to attract all the way from an
island off the south coast of China
across the Pacific to Guam cruising over
Hawaii then drifting North up to Alaska
uh it means the United States had
absolutely no reason to question the
fact that it was a Chinese surveillance
Forum American officials insist the
Chinese still had control of the balloon
while it crossed over Canada and ended
the lower 48 states information that
would have been shared through NORAD
they would be fully apprised of of all
of the information that was being
gathered uh the tracking the whereabouts
that would be shared with Canadian
officials subsequent tracking hasn't
shown any similar objects in NORAD
airspace I'm not aware of any additional
objects that have been reported uh
operating in the space in the last 48
hours Japan has now joined Canada in the
U.S in saying that Chinese spy balloons
have entered into their territory and
that's led the Japanese military to say
they'll change their rules to allow any
future Chinese balloons to be shot down
Donna okay Mackenzie gray thanks and
with me now is Scott Clancy retired
Major General with the Canadian Armed
Forces and former director of operations
at NORAD Scott can you help us
understand this if as has been reported
U.S intelligence watched the Chinese spy
balloon as it launched near China's
South Coast and was monitoring it as it
flew over Canada and the U.S that
suggests the U.S is capable of having
eyes on these high altitude Espionage
balloons how does that square with what
we've heard about the difficulty of
NORAD Raiders radar systems detecting
them
so I think that especially with respect
to the first balloon it was very clear
that those gaps that General van erk the
commander of NORAD talked about and
adjusting the filters had occurred
before this high-level First Chinese
balloon entered into NORAD airspace so
to me it squares very well I think it's
also very telling that that same kind of
information was not present for the
follow-on three objects
sorry what do you mean by the same
information
well so we did not get any information
on the follow-on three objects we don't
know about their attribution or Origins
and right now the leading theory from
the White House and the Pentagon is that
these are of a commercial application
not that I would speculate on that but
that there's a difference between the
fact that the Americans knew about the
first Chinese object versus the other
three I think is telling
telling I guess telling of what though
that's what we're all trying to figure
out
yeah and I think that it's about
answering those questions uh where did
these last three objects come from and
what were they about I think the
recovery operations are going to be
essential at trying to ascertain exactly
where these last three objects came from
but I think what I'm trying to get at is
that the first balloon significant
intelligence gathering capabilities and
a significant intelligence gathering
attribution to China versus the other
three which are still in question
Scott do you think that had someone in
Montana not spotted that original
balloon that was shot down eventually
shot down
that we in the public in the media would
never have known about the possibility
about the reality of surveillance
balloons being overhead
that's a distinct possibility there's a
couple of things that that you know need
to be demystified a little bit about
that you know the Chinese launched that
balloon we know now that the Americans
and by extension NORAD knew about that
but that means the Chinese knew once it
came into NORAD airspace and we were
tracking it they didn't know that we'd
detected it and until that picture was
taken in Montana it's a bit of a cat and
mouse game so that you do not tip your
hat as to the capabilities of the
detection systems that actually defend
the continent now the next question is
you know would it have just if not
discovered by a civilian but floated
through I think that would have been an
interesting case uh in almost impossible
to know whether or not they would have
shot it down anyways and made it public
because there's some benefit to that in
exposing the program but also in
demonstrating that China is not a
straightforward actor so no it is
definitely a possibility Don all right
Clancy thank you so much for speaking
with us
to the escalating humanitarian crisis in
turkey and Syria now the scale of the
disaster is breathtaking more than 41
000 people are now known to have died
and that will continue to rise
incredibly there are still a few
survivors being found
he's buried under debris in Turkey a
mother and her two children were brought
out alive one rescuer told a Turkish
newspaper he held the mother's hand as
she asked for water asked what day it
was and asked about her two children
they were pulled safely out of the
rubble too carefully wrapped in blankets
put on IV drips and rushed to the
hospital
some joy in a sea of sadness the whole
thing though overwhelming for everyone
involved
those fortunate enough to have survived
still have a long road ahead as Ross
Lord reports
with days about to turn into weeks feel
good stories can't obscure the
horrendous reality of a death toll
that's still increasing millions of
people left homeless and their life and
death struggle just to save survivors in
the freezing cold Medical Teams are
working for days on end without sleep to
treat survivors doctors with experience
in Syria including some from Canada are
preparing to return so they are
exhausted colleagues can rest none has
slept so that's where the medical error
becomes it's an issue it's immediate
issues you know you have a surgeon who
is operating for 20 hours home I mean he
needs to he needs to rest as the
combined death toll in turkey and Syria
climbs past 40 000 connecting survivors
with the life-sustaining supplies they
need is a dysfunctional effort
the head of the white helmets rescue
group accuses the United Nations of
failing Syria this a convoy is full of
blankets food medical supplies and Tents
it was organized by Arab tribes but
other convoys have been turned back
including one sent by kurdish-led
authorities from Eastern Syria last week
with both sides blaming each other
the U.N world food program says its
Partners have provided ready to eat
rations for roughly forty five thousand
people in Northwest Syria despite
physical and political obstacles
Canadians who've lost family members are
living a nightmare Muhammad azmal nixad
left Calgary to search for his family in
the devastated Turkish city of karaman
marash he found the bodies of his mother
and sister two other siblings survived
both requiring amputation guy was
sleeping on the streets so that was very
cold too there's nothing there's no
place no shelters there were some
schools I walk into this little schools
but some dead bodies I can't sleep there
which makes heartwarming scenes more
powerful
the 10-member Burnaby Urban search and
rescue team returning to British
Columbia after flying to Turkey the day
after the earthquakes looking for Bible
victims and helping families reunite
they helped save a woman who was trapped
in rubble
those who remain in the devastated zones
are still looking for signs of Hope nine
days after the earthquakes
Ross Lorde Global News
people near Wellington New Zealand were
shaken by a magnitude of 5.7 earthquake
today no damage has been reported but
the country is already dealing with
widespread flooding and destruction
caused by a cyclone and rescue efforts
are still underway to reach survivors
here's what's left of hawks Bay in the
country's Northeast the forecast calls
for more rain in the days ahead
heightening concerns of even more
flooding and landslides January was
already New Zealand's wettest month on
record during a season that is typically
the driest a state of emergency is in
place across the country
anguish in an American courtroom
[Music]
a man responsible for shooting and
killing 10 black people in a racially
motivated attack at a Buffalo New York
grocery store has been sentenced to life
in prison with no chance of parole and
in the courtroom families of the victims
made it clear what they think of him
so I will hurt you so bad you ain't made
me sick you got my family crying I miss
my sister every day I did Three Doors
Down forget
there were powerful Victim Impact
statements and at one point the anger
boiled over one man tried to rush
towards the convicted killer
he had to be held back by the police
nineteen-year-old Peyton Gendron pleaded
guilty to 25 counts including first
degree murder and terrorism motivated by
hate the judge said he deserves no mercy
he did apologize for his crimes he has
yet to be tried on separate federal
charges and could face the death penalty
NATO members in Brussels say they're
committed to ramping up the production
of artillery and Munitions and
conducting more training of Ukrainian
troops that is welcomed by Ukraine but
what it wants even more is Firepower to
defend against the latest Russian
offensive Crystal gomancing Reports
eight Dutch fighter jets are now
stationed in Poland for the next month a
protective measure after Dutch Pilots
escorted Russian aircraft out of what
Poland calls its NATO area of
responsibility protection is also why
Ukraine is pushing for fighter jets from
NATO but defense ministers are holding
their cards close our goal is to make
sure that we give Ukraine additional
capability so that they can be not only
be marginally successful they can be
decisive on on the battlefield in their
upcoming offensive
American President Joe Biden said at the
end of January his country would not
give Ukraine f-16s but many knows have
turned to yeses one military analyst and
former polish Soldier says it's only a
matter of time before jets are delivered
the armed forces are composed of
different
um way of fighting and and planes are
like the puzzles with the tanks and
artillery and the and the Infantry
the more immediate puzzle piece
ammunition for Ukraine and NATO
countries needing to replenish their own
supplies this is now becoming a grinding
War of Attrition and a war attrition is
a war of logistics ukrainians know
exactly the toll the war has taken and
what could still occur they will start a
real offensive campaign certainly they
will use aircrafts from their side
trying to stop our Defense Forces and
they will dominate in the sky Ukraine's
defense minister says he spoke with his
counterparts who indicated they talk
with their governments about what models
would work best but it's not just about
military hardware but maintenance and
training
Crystal commencing Global News London
a surprise political announcement in
Scotland today the first Minister
Nicholas sturgeon who has spearheaded
Scotland's Independence Movement for
eight years announced she's stepping
down
and being no doubt this is really hard
for me
my decision comes from a place of Duty
and of love
tough love perhaps but love nevertheless
for my party and above all for the
country
sturgeon says it was the best job in the
world but that the nature of modern
political discourse is more intense and
brutal than in Years Gone by and she
says that's taken a toll on her she
intends to stay on until a successor is
found she has faced setbacks the UK
Supreme Court blocked her government's
efforts to hold another Independence
referendum and there's controversy over
a double rapist being sent to a female
jail after announcing she was a trans
woman sturgeon is Scotland's longest
serving first Minister and the first
woman to hold the position
cutting ties wise some Caribbean
countries are considering removing King
Charles as head of state
prime minister Justin Trudeau is in the
Bahamas tonight on the agenda as he
meets with 20 Caribbean leaders as
climate change infrastructure and aid
for Haiti a country in crisis from
escalating violence and political
instability Canada's appearance may seem
apt given the Region's historic ties
with the Commonwealth and the British
Monarchy but those are ties a growing
number of countries are considering
cutting turia Israeli reports
that King Charles III is now formally
proclaimed Sovereign of the Commonwealth
of the Bahamas
[Music]
God saved the king
unofficially people on this small island
nation are moving in a different
direction I just think the child is is
tired and well he's got a lot of um
negativity King Charles is preparing for
his coronation in May but countries
across the Caribbean are rethinking
their Royal ties it kind of begged the
question well why are we still holding
on the Bahamas only became independent
50 years ago and is pushing for slavery
reparations from Britain really
perceiving ourselves as a truly
Sovereign Nation and separate from these
ties that once held Us in bondage is
something that we're going to have to
really look at Barbados became the first
Caribbean Nation to leave the monarchy
in 2021. the creation of this Republic
offers A New Beginning Charles then
Prince was welcomed at that ceremony in
his role as the head of the Commonwealth
but William and Kate's Royal Caribbean
tour was much stormier
their visit to Jamaica last year Drew
protests
Caribbeans are also closely watching the
royal family drama involving Harry and
Megan
of course the late Queen remains beloved
by many bahamians there is also the view
the status quo has its benefits easy
diplomacy and natural trade ties if
there's one thing that the Windsors have
been able to do it survive but the queen
is a tough act to follow Charles
certainly is facing an uphill battle
it's going to be really important for
him to show that the monarchy is able to
adapt faster than it did under his
mother ultimately it could be up to the
people of the Bahamas to decide the
Prime Minister has signaled a referendum
is coming on whether to become a
republic and leave ties to the monarchy
behind Donna
Toria Israeli in the Bahamas thanks
A Fantastic Voyage next remembering the
life of American actress and model
Raquel Welch
[Music]
when Raquel Welch made her debut in the
1960s her impact was almost
instantaneous the actress went on to
become a leading sex symbol in Hollywood
she has died today at the age of 82. as
Mike Armstrong reports she's being
remembered as an actress who portrayed
strong female characters over her
50-year career
in her big breakout role Raquel Welch
barely spoke her part in the 1966 film
one Million Years BC was as a caveman
but it was the promotional pinup for the
movie in a fur bikini that turned the
single mother of two and former weather
girl into an international star one
million Million Years BC tonight right
yeah it was a celebrity based Less on
her roles than her features I was
surprised you didn't introduce me as
Raquel Welch and here they come that's
usually
foreign
[Music]
by the roles she was offered in 1972 she
created one for herself producing and
starring in Kansas City bomber she won a
Golden Globe two years later for the
Three Musketeers Welch would go on to
star in 30 Films in a career that
spanned more than five decades but it
wasn't always easy there were the
battles refusing to appear nude and
rumors she was difficult she sued one
studio for defamation when she was fired
from a movie Welch ended up winning more
than the movie made at the box office
she was known throughout her life as an
iconic bombshell in the model of Marilyn
Monroe in fact sharing some of the same
frustrations with the Hollywood star
system for not being able to do more the
title of her 2010 autobiography was
beyond the cleavage just the girl in
that bikini you know she actually wrote
a book according to her family Raquel
Welch died after a short illness she was
82 years old
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Abraham Lake in
Clearwater County Alberta we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you